[Music]
yeah we've spoken a lot i was having a
discussion yesterday we're talking a lot
about good japanese food can we speak
about japanese food that [ __ ]
straight up sucks
be my guest first of all what do you
think sucks you go to the you go to the
izakaya right your boys are ordering
you're all like ordering right you're
getting gyoza yours is good you're
getting the the the uh maybe some
yakimiku right meat on a stick great
yeah sorry yeah i mean you can get
something too maybe i don't know yeah
yeah
it's a coyote
um maybe maybe you got some fried
chicken with the balls
maybe maybe someone ordered something
and you're like oh this is this is fried
chicken right and you eat it you're like
why is it it tastes like bones oh it's
tendons it's like
cartilage like for some reason they're
just like deep fried cartilage and it's
like the worst eating experience oh i
love that
it's like imagine greasy bones it's
literally greasy bones i love what it
feels like it's like you're crunching a
small animal's bones with oil like it's
awful you got to serve dominance i i
agree with you corner it's
they agree on something
it's so bad like do you i don't know how
you like it i used to hate it
if that's
i understand you'll eat anything but
there has to be some dishes where you're
like i'll eat it but like it's kind of
whack right uh olives
what joey's like joey's like uh
fermented fish [ __ ] uh chopped with uh
fermented soy beans i love it can't get
enough but joey's like
i i do not like old
why bro italians are crying right yeah i
mean like i like olive oil i like olive
on pizza but like
why what part is it the is it the is it
the seed
i think it all it's just too strong of a
flavor you like olive oil yeah oh yeah
i mean yeah
i am wearing a lot of like references to
an italian guy but no i'm not excited i
just she's just sucking him out of
nowhere
he doesn't like all this any kind of
[ __ ] fermented [ __ ] but i i i draw
the line
green
joey the man who tried like
who tried like bird fetus and i'm like i
kind of [ __ ] with it
a green animal get that [ __ ] out of here
i when i say i don't like olives it's
not that it's green or black both both
uh green mostly i don't okay yeah i like
black olives i like actually
green are a lot stronger and it's like
and when i say i don't like olives it's
not that if i get a plate of green
olives i'm not gonna eat it at all have
you seen that clip oh sorry it's
interesting but i just have this image
of joey being that person where it's
just a clip of like uh a talk show or
something and the host goes bring out
the olives and like they bring out jar
of olives and this and this one just
starts [ __ ] loose no i don't know
it's the peaches right no it's it's
olives
yeah i don't know i saw another one of
like this woman who had like a deathly
like uh like phobia towards peaches oh i
didn't see that one and like it's like
it's like an ellen show yeah and they're
like oh so you're deathly afraid of
peaches and then she says like the
scientific phobia word for someone who's
afraid of peaches and then behind them
on the giant screen is just a picture of
a peach and this woman just screams out
of the room
and the audience is laughing i'm like
this is horrible she literally just said
she doesn't like me
mary you won't let go of me oh yeah
bring out the art
let's show you that
i just imagine that
no okay
okay okay sorry finish your point
so my point was when i say i don't like
a food
there is very rarely a food that i will
just straight up not eat like when i say
i don't like a food i mean like it
wouldn't be my first choice of eating it
right but if the if i'm at like you know
a house party or something like you know
wine and cheese party and i see some
olives there i'll [ __ ] eat it because
it comes with the thing right but if
someone just gave me some [ __ ] olives
and was like eat it now yeah and i'll be
like i don't know why this makes me so
angry no
i mean it's it's not my first choice
it's like i can live the rest of my life
not eating it anymore i'd rather eat
olives than most izakaya food i think i
i've realized that honestly yeah yeah
really i i think i've i think now that
i've lived in japan for a year i've kind
of come to like not really liking sakai
food because like we okay it's very
limited we are crying
i remember when i first moved to japan i
thought i would never get [ __ ] bored
of this yeah and now two years in i'm
just like can i have a proper meal
please like
yeah it just kind of sucks sometimes you
just want to like you want to eat
healthy but it's impossible
oh yeah
i mean i i think before before anyone
starts to think so i don't go to an easy
guy like ever no no like i'm also like
to the point now where i'm like i could
go an entire month without eating
izakaya food yeah like easily you know
it's like i mean we have yeah yeah but
like every now and then you know if i go
to an isakai with some mates then yeah
i'll eat the food because
not going to be the greatest meal of my
life because because the issue is right
let's say you know british drinking
culture you know you have a meal and
then you have the drinks right yeah and
i thought what's cool about the izakaya
is that there is a whole eating culture
around it where you go to this he's a
guy you have a meal there and you can
drink shocker at the same time until i
realized that most izakaya food is just
basically snacks so you're having a meal
basically just on like snacks or like
meat like it's not it's not like a meal
meal but it's still enough to fill you
up and you never i never go to an
izakaya and get like satisfied
satisfied with the meal you know it's
it's always just
it always feels like you just ate uh
like a bag of like doritos or something
and that was like your meal for the day
that's kind of what it feels like you
don't come out of an izakaya going i had
a great meal you come out full yeah yeah
you come out you come up four you come
out feeling disgusting and you come out
like
i don't know yeah there's so many foods
to them that are just like this is bad
yeah like the
i don't know what a fish it is but it's
just a toenail like it's literally a
toenail like it's oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the uh the what
is it the
what what they call the escape fin skate
fin is it i just call them flat flaps
what are they called oh the sting rays
stingrays yeah no not stingrays just
raised flap flaps
they're the ones that fly like this
they they they bring this out right it
looks like a toenail it looks shiva when
like [ __ ] rolling in his grave steve
would die from a poisonous flap flap
it's like this it's like this [ __ ]
toenail-esque looking thing right and
it's like what does it drive it's dried
stingray or dried rice it comes out and
you have it and you're like it literally
tastes like nothing it doesn't taste of
any what do you mean it tastes like fish
it actually doesn't even taste like fish
it tastes like nothing and it's just
chewy really hard and it's like why why
why are they that's most like
dried fish snacks here
shredded like the shredded fish as well
and like i like the squishy squid stuff
um
the fried squid or like kind of like a
squid game five square there's like
because you can go to convenient like 20
different variations of squid squid it
tastes good i like squid it's good yes
but uh you know and then there's another
thing that's like i don't know what it
is it's like this it's like
uh
it's like octopus it's gooey it's got
like oh takawasa yeah that stuff is
awesome it's like the it's it's octopus
with wasabi you just put it in a blender
oh it's rough oh it's raw yeah i love it
oh it's rough oh it's so rough and joey
of course the first time i came here
made me [ __ ] eat it
and uh it was terrible and then like
half of them
you're like yeah i'm not talking about
fish
[Music]
the thing is every japanese person will
order the order shiraku for you to like
try out but no one's gonna tell you what
it is until you take your first bite
yeah i'm pretty sure that's what i did
with youtube right yeah exactly that's
[ __ ] hilarious